[MUSIC]
It's crucial for leaders today to be able
to communicate effectively.
If as a leader you want to influence the
direction of an organization, or
the output of your employees and your team
members.
The best tool in your tool kit as a
leader, is effective and
clear communication.
[MUSIC]
The first place I being when I work with a
leader who is trying to communicate more
effectively, is to teach a very simple
framework that allows you to
create a strategy, before you ever write,
or ever speak.
And the heart of that strategy is just the
word aim.
Who is my audience?
What is my intent?
And what is my message?
If, if a leader can think through
audience, intent, and
message, as they're creating an email, or
a Tweet, or a report, or
a presentation and really distill within
each of those three pieces what
is it they want to achieve with the
audience that they're speaking to.
That's the first place to become more
effective as a leader who communicates.
[MUSIC]
The more I know about the group of people
that I am trying to communicate with.
What inspires them to action?
Where do they gather?
What resources do they rely on?
What sources of news do they read?
What are their peer groups of influence?
The more I understand the audience, the
more I can decide what's the best vehicle
or multiple vehicles that I might want to
use in order to communicate with them.
When I'm only communicating with one
person, and
I'm doing it interpersonally with just two
people sitting in a room,
I have the full benefit of both the verbal
and
the non-verbal communication between me
and that other person.
As a leader, I don't have that freedom
where every message I deliver,
I can deliver one on one.
So as I start communicating to a small
group of people,
a larger group of people, a very large
group or
a mass audience, I have to also expand the
different vehicles that I might use.
Choosing the vehicle or vehicles that
gonna be most effective,
based on the audience analysis that I've
done.
[MUSIC]
Any time that a leader is standing up in
front of a group of people to
deliver a message, there are three aspects
to that communication.
There's the verbal, which are the actual
words that,
that person says to the audience.
If I was to do a transcript of everything
that was said,
that's the verbal component of the
communication.
There's also the vocal component of
communication, how loud or
how soft, how much I use pauses for
emphasis, or how rapid
I deliver to show a sense of excitement
and enthusiasm for what's coming.
And that's the vocal aspect of
communication.
But the third and, many researchers argue,
the most powerful aspect of communication
is the visual,
the nonverbal communication, my sense of
gestures, eye contact, movement.
Even how I'm dressed and the posture that
I use,
all is a part of my presence as a leader
in front of a group of people.
So when the visual, the vocal and the
verbal all come together effectively,
then a leader is able to have a sense of
executive presence,
as they deliver a presentation, share a
story or
have a conversation with the teams that
they are leading.
[MUSIC]